Optionals are also necessary for
downcasting in swift.
Here's what I mean by downcasting.
Occasionally objects are labeled
as members of a particular class.
But can also act as
a member of a subclass,
to downcast is to cast such an object
as an instance of its subclass.
You'll see a lot of downcasting
with optionals when you start
interacting with classes like UI
storyboard and the app delegate.
But let's start with a simpler example.
Here we have a beverage class with two
subclasses, hot drink and cold drink.
We also have an array of beverages.
Because there are both hot drinks and
cold drinks in this array,
the array must be of class beverage.
There are no mixed type arrays in Swift.
Let's say we wanted to loop through
the array of beverages, And
generate a message that will
offer each of the drink choices.
When we loop through the array,
each item will be treated as a beverage.
But we really want our message
to be more specific than that.
It would be better if we could cast a
beverage as a hot drink or a cold drink.
Before offering a drink to a guest.
Now, there are two points here
I'd like you to remember.
First focus on this piece of code here.
When we grab a drink from the array
we don't know whether it can be
cast to a cold drink or not.
So we use an optional cast
with an as question mark.
Also known as a type cast operator.
By casting the item from the array
as an optional ColdDrink,
we're saying this item could be
a ColdDrink or it could be nil.
Here's the second point
I'd like you to remember.
As we know, optionals can't be
used until they're unwrapped.
So if you use the as question
mark typecast operator,
you also have some unwrapping to do.
Just like we've done previously with
other optionals we can use a flat.
Remember that the if let construction
checks to see if an optional
has a value.
If it does have a value
this code gets executed and
we can use cold drink in our message.
If it doesn't have a value
the ELSE block is executed, and
the beverages cast as a hot drink.
And here in the sidebar we can
see those custom messages.
But let's not forget about
the exclamation points.
Although they are risky
they can also be convenient
in cases where we're confident about the
identity of the object being downcast.
Let's say we're a coffee shop.
We only serve hot coffee.
But for some reason a method from an
Apple library is returning in array of
items of class beverage.
If we never deal in cold drinks,
we might boldly downcast
beverages to hot drinks using as!.
As we know, optionals with exclamation
points automatically unwrap.
So our downcasting work is done.
No if let required.